also nach wie vor wird nach der
unglücksursache gesucht aber ich gehe
jetzt mal ein wenig aus dem bild wir
sehen hinter mir ganz ganz viel schaum
der meeres schauen soll eine große rolle
gespielt haben wir haben gerade noch
ungefähr 15 meter weiter in richtung
schauen gestanden aber es kam dann eine
windböe und wir waren komplett wie
eingeschneit also dann kann man sich
wirklich vorstellen wenn hier schnell
der wind dreht auf der nordsee dass man
dann tatsächlich nicht mehr weiß wo oben
und unten ist wahrscheinlich war es der
wind in kombination mit hohen wählen die
sehr schnell gedreht haben und dann
sollen die surfer links auf die klippe
des strandes gespült worden sein und
eventuell da die orientierung verloren
haben und sollen heute die
bergungsarbeiten wieder anlaufen um die
leiche des letzten opfers zu bergen
ja also ganz schön wünscht sich
natürlich und vor allem die surfer cube
community und die angehörigen des noch
vermissten und toten servers dass die
leiche schnell geborgen wird heute
morgen als wir zum strand gekommen sind
waren schon marinetaucher dar
sie haben sich das hafenbecken angesehen
um zu gucken ob der surfer eventuell
dort angespült worden ist momentan ist
auch die küstenwache und die küsten
rettung auf dem meer und versucht den
grund mit einem sonar einem
selbstfahrenden roboter abzufahren um zu
gucken ob man dort spuren der leiche
finden kann
es wird heute wieder ein helikopter
starten es wird der strand mit
flugzeugen abgeflogen
die leute wollen gewissheit haben wo ihr
verstorbener kumpel ist ganz klar muss
diese leiche gefunden werden michael
letzte frage zu dem schaum ist das
normal dort in der gegend hätten die
surfer damit rechnen müssen oder können
dass diese gefahr besteht oder tritt das
ja unregelmäßig dort auf diese
diese schaumbildung also diese diese
schaumbildung ist wohl generell kein
problem ist handelt sich um algen die
bei besonderer witterung ein protein
ausschütten und dann in verbindung mit
schmids sturm mit wind und wasser gibt
es einen ganz ganz klebrigen schleim das
war wohl hier bekannt also alle leute
mit denen wir gesprochen haben sagten
das sei bekannt gewesen aber diese
schnell ändernde wettersituation muss
für die surfer die nun wirklich cracks
waren alle haben gesagt diese jungs
seien durchtrainiert gewesen selbst
lifeguards sie hätten ihr leben nicht
riskiert werden wirklich die nur die der
hauch der der möglichkeit gegeben wir
sind wäre dass die jungs sich verletzen
oder in gefahr hätten geraten können
also man kann davon ausgehen dass sie
wussten was sie tun das hat uns auch
gestern der nacht bürgermeister gesagt
eine art offizieller sprecher des
lachens und der freizeitgestaltung hier
in scheveningen er hat gesagt ohne
zweifel waren jungs absolute cracks und
sie hätten ihr leben nie aufs spiel
gesetzt wenn es einen ansatz gegeben
hätte dass man bei diesem wetter nicht
raus darf man geht davon aus dass sie
wirklich in verbindung mit dem mit den
wellen mit dem wind mit dem schaum die
orientierung verloren haben und dann
nicht mehr wusste wo oben und unten ist
und dann leider verstorben sind